In 1983, American psychologist, Howard Gardner
published a book [Frames of Mind] with a theory
that there are nine types of intelligence:
To understand this theory,
let’s consider the problem of the council of Newtown,
who wants to build a bridge
over the dangerous railroad tracks.
But there is strong opposition from some citizens
who don't like change.
Despite the demonstrations,
the council agrees to go ahead
and then hires a team of 9 experts
from Smarts & Co. to get the job done.
Let’s introduce each one of them:
Miss Picture Smart played a lot of hide and
seek when she was young.
And she loved puzzles.
She has lots of imagination and ideas about shapes.
Her job in the project is to create the plans,
make the designs and build a prototype.
Mr. Nature Smart loves trees
and he has great ideas of how to minimize the impact
of a bridge on the environment.
He started thinking of these issues
ever since the first time he went
summer camping with dad.
He developed a passion for all living beings.
Mrs. Number Smart is a nerd.
She always was.
In the playground, she was already calculating
the sand buckets needed to build the biggest castle.
In high-school, she was the Chess-master
and everyone was so proud her.
She will calculate the costs,
study workers safety issues
and estimate the raw materials needed.
Her concerns are the budget, resources and risks.
Mrs. People Smart arranges a town meeting
and goes out to invite all the citizens to come.
She was always good with people.
As a kid, she spent most of the time outside
with her neighbours.
As a teenager, her mom explained to her that
most people mean well,
even if they have trouble showing their feelings.
Today, everyone loves her
and she does a great job convincing everyone,
even the most outspoken opponents.
Miss Word Smart has been keeping a diary since she was young.
In math class, she wrote poems
and during field trips she didn't talk to others but
instead studied the travel guide.
For the big town hall meeting, she writes
a convincing speech,
filled with hard facts, big feelings and good metaphors.
Ever since he was young, Jimmy Life Smart
knew how to talk and entertain.
Today he shows his skills on the stage.
He starts his speech with a personal story
about his cat that once got lost on the train tracks.
Then he delivers all the arguments
with so much passion,
that all citizens can only agree with the plan.
Ms. Word Smart is delighted
to see the impact of her work.
Now, as construction starts, Mr. Body Smart
gets ready to get things done.
Even the children are inspired by his power
and want to help.
During the breaks, he plays football with his team,
which is fun and teaches him balance skills
he later can use high up in the sky.
Madame Self Smart knows a lot about feelings:
our fears, joys and angers.
She learned this from her own past
where she started to reflect on herself.
But she also reads a lot about feelings
and talks to her friends about their emotions.
During the construction, she is the positive force,
motivates those that feel down,
and solves tensions that can come up
when we collaborate.
While everyone is busy finishing the bridge,
Mrs. Music Smart writes a song for the grand opening.
She has loved music ever since started playing piano.
Later she moved on to Hip Hop and Jazz-Dance.
At the opening ceremony of the bridge,
she and her band perform the song.
It was a fantastic team effort from all 9
of the Smart and Co.
In 2016, Gardner said that he is considering
adding pedagogical intelligence, or “teach smart”.
What do you think?
Is he right or wrong about these types,
or are IQ, EQ or other forms of intelligence better classifications?
Please be teach smart, and tell us what you
think about intelligence theory in the comments below.